snaggle-eye when I was watching this was
like I think we're about two years out
like this movie could take place two
years from now we're almost there folks
technology is crazy
[Music]
this circle so the circle is a movie
starring Emma Watson featuring Tom Hanks
and John boyega they're in it but it's
Emma Watson's movies and she's in her
dead-end job so her friend gets her an
interview at this company called the
circle she lands it now she's in the
circle what is the circle the circles
like Google meets social medias like if
Google and Facebook went splat basically
if Google Plus ever actually took off
and became the social media presence
Google wanted it to be it would be the
circle and the circle is ever-changing
ever-evolving more people are being
watched for the sake of data and so this
company can adapt to make life better
for people the speed more people get
watch it's an interesting premise that
make you case for it in the movie but it
isn't very slow basically that's the
whole point of the movie the interesting
thing about this movie is this concept
movie makes a great case force like if
you could tag and keep track of every
kid no more kids will get kidnapped how
rad would that be you watch it in the
movie you're like yeah that'd be great
without secrets maybe mankind can reach
its true potential but at what cost
that's the thing you got to think about
I personally love me my private time not
only because I love the horn I just like
putting on my headphones zoning out with
music into my own little world of
nothing just me and the tunes in my head
being watched all the time to be kind of
cool for about a day and a half and I'd
be like all right bug off I rely really
need my space what really works in the
movie with Tom Hanks first of all I know
it's Emma Watson's movie I'll get to her
in a second but Tom Hanks oh my god Tom
Hanks it's been about four or five
scenes in the entire movie handful of
scenes
completely crushes it this dude is
charming he's electric if there is going
to be a super Skynet Overlord in human
form I would want it to be Tom Hanks
character in here like I said John Blake
is in it again not in it enough for me
to actually reference in this movie like
if you were anyone else I wouldn't
represent in the review but a John
boyega I like John blegh
I find it really perplexing that he will
always be in America you'll never have a
British accent ever not in a movie
anyway it's really weird because he
doesn't realize Emma Watson spine like
Emma Watson's that girl that's perfectly
sir
and she's fine it's like oh we need a
female in a movie we need a girl great
Emma Watson will do and we love her
because a Harry Potter is fine and dandy
but thus far I love Emma Watson because
I see the potential in Emma Watson but
she has yet to deliver a role that makes
me really really oh my god Emma Watson
other than the great conceptual premise
and Tom Hanks completely crushing it was
a bit choppy and forgettable in Ireland
which is a bummer I saw the trailer I
was like this movie could be that it
sides not quite really it's because they
need to do so much in a short amount of
time they need to get these characters
from A to Z in that much time and I
almost wish this movie was going for an
Oscar like it came out in November and
it was a super Oscar bait movie so it's
like three hours long does an Oscar bait
movie they all are so at that point you
can just like really draw it out and
have the characters go to these places
go from A to B to C and have it feel
organic and natural but emma watson has
to become the favorite in the circle
like that and say i alright to half an
hour in she's the favorite no Paxson's
in the movie i almost forgot to mention
Bill Packard and bummed me out I totally
I didn't know Bill Paxton was in this
movie then I saw him I was like aha belt
backs is really sad he's just gone way
too sir not really a critique on the
movie I just wanted to talk about Bill
Paxton for a second because I did but
this movie really trips over itself out
of point because there's a thing that
happens that is a bad thing that happens
but really it was just a negligent thing
that happened that led to something bad
so in the end it's like oh we got to
take down Tom Hanks and Patton Oswalt
because they're dicks right the movie
really didn't get me there until Hanks
was super charismatic on stage so right
there I'm like you got to be hiding
something I don't trust you but the
movie never really got me on board as
Tom Hanks being a day I didn't know he
was a piece of [ __ ] I never really felt
he was a piece of [ __ ] he's a little
shifty I so you know he has ulterior
motives and he says one thing the Patton
Oswald when it's all going down at the
end where you're like maybe you are [ __ ]
human being it's the only real
confirmation we have and he is a [ __ ]
human being other than that the only
thing we know about his characters that
he genuinely wants to make the world a
better place maybe this isn't the way to
go about it but that's what he want
again wish they had more time for more
information guys in the end the circle
is all right great concept I tip my hat
to the concept of the circle interesting
premise with questions that need to be
asked in this technological day and it's
however nothing really grabbed me in the
movie sunk its claw
like Emma Watson gets an internship and
then things happening in the movie and
teeing up for the set up for the great
question is not driving home the point
of the question in that the movies a bit
forgettable when you walk out you're
like ad shoulda woulda coulda done in
the end I will say the circle tragically
probably going to be forgotten in t
minus a couple days ya already forgot I
say that because it's not really I don't
think a drink is going to make this
movie better probably put you to sleep
alright guys so the circle have you seen
it what did you think about it or what
your favorite movie that makes you ask
the questions the important questions
those social questions of life whatever
it is whatever you think comment below
let me know and as always if you like
what you've seen here and you want to
see more click right here to see more
[Music]